all right my talk on the table is
actually something somebody else is
going to be talking about and it's an
exclusive announcement from Soccer Star
Ali Krieger it's an announcement you
will only see on CBS mornings Krieger
has been a key part of U.S women's
soccer for more than a decade now as she
joined the National Team back in 2008
and since then the star Defender has
played in 108 games for Team USA
including three World Cup finals helping
the team win two World Cup championships
in 2015 and 2019. Krieger currently
plays for Gotham football club FC in the
national women's soccer league and off
the field she is an outspoken advocate
for the lgbtq plus community and along
with her U.S teammates she pushed for
equal pay for female athletes and that
led to legislation signed by President
Biden this year ensuring All Team USA
women get the same pay as men in their
Sport and Ali Krieger joins us now Ali
good morning I said this is your talk of
the table
you've got something to announce you
have the floor
yeah so much first and foremost for
inviting me here but I do want to make a
big announcement that this will be my
final and and last year playing
professional soccer and I'm so excited
to celebrate with my friends my family
my teammates coaching staff and and just
everyone most importantly the fans over
the years and celebrate this year since
it'll be my last a lot of people are
sitting at home going no well I know and
you're saying it so calmly how do you
know that this is how did you know that
this was a time for you did anything
happen yes
um I think as an athlete where you hear
it before a lot of athletes say you just
know the right time and I feel that this
is the right time for me I've given so
much uh to the game and I've gotten a
lot in return but I I feel it my body
also feels it
um your butt's still playing very well
though thank you thank you I you know
and I wanna I wanna keep it like that
and um and end on a high and so my my
focus is fully on Gotham FC and winning
an end of baseball championship this
year so make no mistake that is the most
important goal for me this season and um
and then you know at the end we'll see
what happens wow yeah you've got a
season to focus on uh but we were
talking in the Green Room you've been
playing organized soccer for 32 years of
your life you have given a lot to the
sport we actually have a picture of you
as a youngster I don't know how young
will maybe we'll get the picture up and
you can tell us there you are
yes what would you tell that little girl
about the career ahead for her and what
advice would you have really for all the
little girls who are now that age
wanting to be you yeah I mean looking
back
I'm so proud that I've had the career
that I've had and starting out playing
organized soccer at you know age five
six years old chasing my brother around
um and you know and trying to beat him
and everything but I would just tell her
listen couldn't you can only control two
things really it's your work ethic and
your attitude towards something and also
don't be afraid to take risks because I
took a big risk going overseas right
after school and graduated at Penn State
and it led me to my dream job of playing
with the US Women's National Team and so
I feel that talking to that young girl
there's so much ahead of her but those
two things of advice I I would probably
you know give back or your lovely wife
ashlyn's here she knows a little thing
or two we were together in the Green
Room about retiring because she and
she's a professional soccer player as
well yes you know that yes and she
announced her retirement last year what
has she told you about what this process
is like she's been very very happy she's
so excited you were for her for both for
both I think her exact quote was I'm
glad to have my wife back is glad to
have my wife back no but we have two
beautiful kids and
um you know we we've given the game two
under two two under two yeah and uh
we've given the game so much and you
know
um just using our platform for speaking
up on issues that really we believe in
and we want to continue that work
outside of soccer and we want to make an
impact yes we've made an impact on the
field for so many years but now it's
focusing on making that impact off the
field and I think
um also just having family time and
spending quality time together with our
two kids and we haven't had that in in
so long and or ever so I think that's
what we're looking forward to most and
and I think she's very very excited and
happy about that so how excited do you
think slow to notion are going to be
once you retire to see you every day at
home with them it's going gonna be
exciting because you know you you try to
find that balance now as a working mom
to really give 100 when you walk into
the door and you you want your kids to
see you happy and so I think that
they're going to be even happier because
we're going to be even more excited to
be home uh you know more consistently
and so that's something that I really
look forward to and not really having a
schedule being able to you know wake up
um with them and then you know spend
days with them and then put them to bed
it's like the times that we really
cherish as moms maybe coach a little
Youth Soccer maybe it's going to be hard
for me to sit on the sideline I'll tell
you that but um no I would any sport
that they want to play or anything that
way they want to choose to do we're
going to be full Ali Krieger your legacy
will be what in your words as we say
goodbye you know I want to leave the
game better than where I found it and I
really believe that you know I've used
my voice my platform to try to impact
um you know future Generations that are
going to fall in our footsteps right and
you know we have done so much like I
said on the field but the impact off the
field I think I'm most proud of
um as as a professional soccer player
Riley Krieger we thank you
congratulations season ahead we
appreciate you being here the 2023
National Women's Soccer League season
returns this Saturday with coverage
across CBS Sports platforms all season
long